at the heart of any vibrant research
community you'll find a diverse range of
scientists you're also likely to find a
robust internship program like the one
at Microsoft Research this summer
MSR welcomed another stellar group of
interns who had the opportunity to learn
collaborate and network with colleagues
and mentors who will impact their lives
for years to come on today's podcast
you'll hear the stories of three of
these interns each of whom came to
Microsoft research from a different
field with a different story in a
different perspective but all of whom
share MSRs passion for finding
innovative solutions to the world's
toughest challenges you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
[Music]
Kirstin beret is a grad student who
lives at the intersection of psychology
and technology
she joined researcher Oskar Rose way in
the HCI group and spent the summer
making temporary tattoos a little
smarter
[Music]
Kirsten Bray welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me tell us a bit
about your personal story it's an
unconventional one for this industry
what's your background and what got you
interested in high-tech research so it's
actually kind of funny I have a degree
in psychology and I got into
human-computer interaction by spending a
lot of time in my school's makerspace I
attended Spelman College and we had a
kind of incoming Innovation Lab where we
were still trying to kind of piece
together that space and encourage
students to explore the intersection of
the Arts and Technology we've got these
elements of understanding human behavior
and human thinking and then they
converge where you lend them together to
make more usable and more engaging types
of technologies it was really
interesting kind of even imagining the
possibilities of something like that and
the affordances going into a field like
that would give me as far as being able
to maximize the existing knowledge that
I have in the existing passions that I
have you say you just graduated with a
degree in psychology from Spelman yeah
so are you in graduate school now or
what are you what's your situation yes
so I'm actually going into graduate
school in the fall I'll be attending
DePaul University and I'll be starting a
human-computer interaction program so
I'm hoping I can get the technical
skills there that I need to kind of
bridge that gap from psychology to
actually go deeper into human-computer
interaction wow so this internship is a
like gap summer oh yeah it is the
perfect kickoff point for me right now
because I feel like a lot of the
thoughts and the interests that I had as
an undergraduate we're kind of just fear
I'm just like these are the kinds of
things that I'm interested in this is
the kind of space that I feel like I
would work well in based off of the
stuff that I know and now it's actually
time to get in and understand what a
human-computer interaction research
environment is actually like and then
understand what kind of skills I need to
get to be in a space like this and be
productive in a space like this how did
you come to be an intern at MSR then
this summer I had been working on a
project as an undergraduate I was
working with a professor who is trying
to work on a device that would allow you
to take pictures through a microscope
using your smartphone and so while I was
working on that project I was trying to
understand like okay what is the user
experience process gonna be like what
are users going to have difficulties
with how can we improve this device so
that it can be the most usable for our
student I didn't really know where to
start with some kind of research like
this and so I asked my professor for
information about anybody who would be
able to help me out with understanding
how to gather this kind of data and so
she bounced me over to Melissa poon who
is a xboxone researcher and by the end
of our conversation like she told me
that MSR had opportunities for
internships and so I just took a leap of
faith and decided to apply and so when I
sent in my application one of the
researchers I wanted to work under was
asta and I'm very interested in art and
Technology intersections and so I asked
to work with her and she had seen my
portfolio and my resume and thought that
I might be a useful addition to the team
and I was excited to work with her tell
us about the project thing that you're
working on for this internship so I am
now actually working on the smart cities
they're tattoos that connect to a
Bluetooth enabled microcontroller that
takes in capacitive touch input and so
they allow you to interface with
different devices like phones or
computers and they can also be used as a
power strip for an LED if you just want
to have like a kind of decorative yeah
like if you just want to be decorative
you can do that but if you want to have
some
functionality equipped with it like
turning on lights or calling people from
your phone then you can totally do that
just using a simple tattoo and some your
arm yeah just like on your arm and like
or wherever yeah we've had a lot of back
tattoos we've seen arm tattoos I've
actually had some fun experiences
augmenting people's existing tattoos
with the smart tattoos and building off
of tattoos that people already have
because people already have been putting
things on their bodies and so it's like
why not add functionality to that beauty
it's been a really exciting project to
work on it's definitely right up my
alley with this intersection of
creativity and understanding user
experiences and understanding new
technologies I'm kind of exploring the
design aspect of this and like exploring
like okay what more can you do with the
actual visuals of this how can you make
something that's functional but also has
this beautiful form and so it's a very
basic simple interaction but it allows
people to kind of see what's possible
and understand that there aren't really
very many limitations with this kind of
technology as far as what you want it to
look like or what it can do so let's
drill in a little bit there because it
is interesting to me when you you know
you see someone with a sleeve tattoo and
you can add functionality to that where
could this go what might an application
beyond just you know turning on your
lights or whatever have you dreamed
about that at all it's very funny like
because we've found stuff lots of
different use cases but certain things
like if you are I don't know a small
child and like you can't really memorize
phone numbers but you can put on like
cute little temporary tattoo sticker and
be like hey like if you get lost called
mommy just tap your tattoo it'll just
call somebody we had a hackathon project
that was really cool where somebody was
designing the tattoos where if you touch
somebody else's tattoo then you could
exchange music files with them and so
just having that kind of yeah having
that kind of affordance where you've got
like all sorts of different
possibilities whether it be like just
fun or a little bit more
client Awards like practical usage there
are so many different possibilities and
so it's like what would you do with a
button or a trackpad if it was on your
skin I know if somebody came to our
office and was talking about how
people's tattoos like they always have
different stories about their tattoos
and wouldn't it be cool if you could
just touch somebody's tattoo and maybe
it could display the story of what this
thing is about and so it allows people
to communicate better it allows people
to be a bit more creative with their
interfaces and actually choose what they
want to say with their technology so
this hackathon you talked about you guys
called it the hack attack oh that was so
fun so we have basically a two-part
challenge and we did a workshop first
and we did that over in the garage and
had a bunch of people attend and just
get their feet wet with experiencing
what working with smart tattoos was like
and seeing what kind of ideas they could
come up with and so we took the
challenge and extended it out from there
and created this hack a tad challenge
for the hackathon and had people do the
same thing with a little bit more time
and ask them to use these materials and
come up with new designs and fresh ideas
and so we got two things out of this one
we got all sorts of cool ideas about
just what people were actually
interested in and we also got a good
feel for what people are actually
experiencing when they work with these
things because we're hoping to release a
smart tattoo tin and actually allow
people to play with these and really be
engaged with the making process yeah
yeah who could get the kits our
hackathon winners will be actually
getting some kids to play around with
and hopefully we'll be able to release a
second generation kit that has a smaller
more easy-to-use board and more easy to
use connectors and hopefully that kit
will be something that can be launched
and turned into something bigger that's
more available for public use still
ambitions for the future but I'm very
hopeful we've gotten a lot of good
feedback and so I'm excited because I
really want to see this after I leave
like I want to just go to a store and
see there's this kid because I would
totally use that right and then you
could say I
the beginning talk about the people that
you're working with who's your advisor
and the group you're in what have you
learned from them in this experience my
mentor is us - Rose Way and she's been
great she's full of creative energy and
just an awesome person to work with I
think she's always been very supportive
is the things that I've been doing and
encouraging me to kind of look at things
in new ways or try out different things
and you've also got Paul he's a he's our
engineer on the team and so he does the
software side of things and so he's been
actually helping me with one of the
other tattoos and I'm doing where it
senses where you're touching he's
actually doing the programming for that
and so hey quite appreciate him like I
feel like everyone who I've worked with
here has been very positive it's always
very positive energy like everybody's
very receptive to new ideas everybody's
willing to help and we just have a lot
of fun so Kirsten what's next on the
horizon for you immediately you're going
back to graduate school at DePaul and
what do you hope to get and do and where
do you want to land what are your dreams
for the future I've seen so many
different possibilities I think being at
MSR obviously academia is looking a
whole lot more appealing research people
are really very intense at MSR like and
I love it I love that intensity like
where people are just so attached to
this project and they want to see it
through to the end and so I like that
spirit and that vibe of just creating
and exploring new things and so I would
definitely like to go into research
sometime in the future but I'd also like
to go into industry and kind of
experience what it's like to be a
designer on the product half of things
and like work in that kind of field so I
feel like it's an open box for me right
now but there are certain things like I
definitely do want to get my PhD I would
like to right now I'm looking at
human-computer interaction PhD programs
and also perhaps digital media programs
yeah but there are so many things like I
feel like there are so many more
possibilities right now and so I am
open to it all and hoping for just lots
of new experiences
Kirsten ray we are excited to see where
you're gonna end up we'll keep an eye on
your career and your work and hopefully
we'll see you on the cover of Wired
magazine one day wait I is a math whiz
with a need for speed
he spent his summer working with
researcher Kim Lane in the cryptography
group to accelerate computation on
homomorphic encrypted data using GPUs
[Music]
wait I welcome to the podcast today it's
great to have you here yeah thank you
nice to be here tell us a bit about your
personal story so originally I'm from
China I did my high school and
university in China and then I comes
here to Worcester Polytechnic Institute
it message was it for master degree yeah
and during my first master there I
performed well in the class and they
offer me to do a PhD in the lab and I
accepted and ever since I've been
working in this field cryptography did
you know from the get-go that you wanted
to do cryptography let's just say you're
good at math is that the natural place
that you go or I mean what got you
interested in that particular field
actually before taking that course I
don't know what's the meaning of
cryptography the English word so after
that I figure out okay cryptography is
not about solving some puzzles is
actually about using mathematics to
build a magical scheme that protects the
data so I was very interested and I'm
amazed where are you in the process of
your degree yeah I'm still in Worcester
right now I'm about to finish my PhD so
after this intern this summer I'll go
back to the school start planning for my
dissertation and schedule for defense
and in fact Kristen louder my manager
here
she is going to be in the county board
what is your dissertation going to be on
and so previously I've been doing
research on these homomorphic encryption
and also I have a specialization in
doing it really fast on GPUs and this is
going to be the theme of my dissertation
how did you come to be an intern at MSR
it was a really good chance that last
year in summer microcell researched the
crypto group actually hosted one
workshop for the standardization of
homomorphic encryption and they've
invited a lot of very famous scholars to
Microsoft research that the campus and I
actually I came as man wiser and that's
how I met Christine came and everyone in
the group and we introduced our work
everyone was thinking okay we never know
on GPU it can be so fast and Christine
got interested yeah she asked me so
would you like to do an internship next
year summer so we scheduled it out yeah
and that's why I came here well give us
a little overview of homomorphic
encryption and what its purpose is
basically it's not just any cipher or
encryption scheme it does not only do
the encryption protected data but also
allow computation and it encrypted data
which wasn't possible right before so
just to clarify if I encrypt data and
then I want to do something with it as
you say operate on it
traditionally I've had to unencrypt it
to be able to do something with it
right yeah this homework encryption you
don't have to decrypt the data but you
can perform commutation and whoever did
the commutation return you the result in
an encrypted form where you are the one
who owns the data you're the only one
who can decrypt the result so you've got
the key nobody else gets the key to
decrypt it to be able to operate on it
and then you can do this homomorphic
encryption operate on the day to get it
back and then you can see what happened
yeah correct tell us about the project
that you're working on maybe starting
with the problem
the speed of homomorphic encryption to
begin with ten years ago as people
started building home or fie encryption
schemes mathematically and also doing a
software or hardware implementations at
the beginning the encrypted data are so
large compared to clear data and also
the commutation unencrypted it was so
slow micro cell research has started
this library cut the CEO library which
is a simple encrypted arithmetic library
so the goal of building these libraries
to in simplify how to use home of
encryption and push for more efficient
permutation and for past three years the
performance the security the user
experience everything has been improved
by a lot and they would like to see how
can we accelerate the library ecology
PUE a different hard work and we also
have another intern who's doing the
implementation on a fpga
which is we are really trying all the
hardware devices to see what we can get
so the speed-up of the runtime is what
you're looking for yeah exactly the
faster the better
yeah and according to our experience on
a GPU usually you can achieve at least
20 times speed-up and if the scheme is
really well designed you can reach to
others of magnitudes which is a Henry
times and how FPGA you can achieve
something similar so tell us about your
library this is a fairly unique
innovative thing that you've been
working on yeah so suppose I'm a data
company on a client side I can provide
them in software to encrypt their data
or doing decryption later and the
library itself also provides service for
the data company who can design an
application of machine learning or
genomic data analysis they provide the
data analysis service to the clients in
an encrypted form with the help of C
library everything can be simplified
they don't have to understand too much
about the home of encryption they just
know this is realizable and using our
library make your life much easier
so how has that played out I mean is
this available yet or is it still in the
research phase or where is it so the
research never stop so what we do is
that we keep releasing new versions of
the library and the library is currently
published and their Microsoft license
and we do have a lot of clients and
other groups who are using this library
internally at Microsoft Research what do
you hope to see in this area in the
future we do see a promising future in
this area because it's still very young
over nine or ten years so far yeah and
now because they are an urgent need for
privacy protection and there's a
regulations and laws making towards this
direction I think home of encryption
have a much brighter future tell us
about your adviser and the group you're
working in what have you learned from
the people you're working with this
summer in our group we have four five
full-time employees and also we have a
five new interns this summer so mainly
I'm the one who's working on GPU we do
have a lot of meetings together because
different people have different opinions
and they might be able to see for
example my colleagues will see what did
I do wrong in these procedures and they
can correct me and give me another idea
that's very helpful
so it's group constructive criticism
right right who's your adviser so Kim
Lane he's the one who make this new
library really useful right now and ends
up being used by many other groups like
we have people working on machine
learning people working on compilers and
everyone is curious about how can we use
this and they are trying to use it right
now hopefully we can come up with some
joint work and end up in a product yeah
so when you came here did you bring this
project with you the GPU speed-up
scenario for homomorphic encryption so
accelerating see you live
Rhian GPU has been a plan by the
microcell research and also in our group
however in this field requires some
special skills and not many people in
this area have actually do it cheaper
implementations and one of them and I
was lucky to have the best performance
out of it when it came here they just
told me ok
you are specializing these please do
these just go tell us a bit about the
performance like that you've alluded to
that you had the best performance what
are we comparing that to traditionally
we were just comparing suppose you have
an algorithm I implemented on a GPU and
achieve probably more than Henry time
speed-up compared to running it on the
CPU even compared to the bad CPU
implementation could be many times more
and now this is not just a simple
algorithm it's a whole library and even
the algorithm itself is hard to
implement it involves a lot of research
work because talking about how to do
this computation is one thing actually
adding two numbers on a computer is
different and different hardware is a
new area this summer I've been working
on accelerating Co we are expecting more
than 20 times at least hopefully again
faster the better
what's next for you why this fall I will
be focusing on finishing my PhD and
doing education and defence after that I
would like to go in industry and
Microsoft research actually is one of
the best destination for me if I can
come back my bet is yes Thanks so but a
career in research continues yeah I feel
this area is too promising to leave
right now I would like to stay in this
area and continue my research I think
right now internally we have been doing
something very meaningful and we do have
some prototypes that is driven by a home
of encryption they show very good result
not ideally
practical but good enough for you to
consider using it wait I this podcast
has been a very good result thanks for
coming in and sharing this with us is so
interesting
thank you Sarah berry may be the only
MSR intern who was also a professional
ballerina but her passion now is using
technology to help protect the
environment
she joined researcher Dan Morris and
spent her summer building AI models for
motion-triggered cameras used in
wildlife conservation saraberry welcome
to the podcast thank you you have a
really I see this to a lot of people but
you really do have an interesting unique
unconventional path to this place tell
us a bit about your personal story and
then we'll get to the details of what
you're doing later but I want to hear
about you like you said I definitely had
an unconventional path to tech so I grew
up here in Seattle and I moved alone at
16 to Atlanta to dance Atlanta ballet
ballet was my entire life I absolutely
loved it I continued on from there to
dance in San Francisco and New York City
actually all over the world but actually
while I was in Atlanta I was living
really close to Georgia Tech and I was
really broke because I was a ballerina
and Georgia Tech would have these open
talks that would have free food I
started going to these talks and hearing
about all of this really amazing
research basically just as a ticket for
free food and I actually wasn't even
sure I was supposed to be there you're
probably supposed to be a student but I
lived close enough it was fine and I
more and more as I was hearing what
people are doing really started this
stink like okay well I can't do ballet
forever and I always really loved school
like maybe I'll go back after ballet and
become an engineer
so I can help solve these problems for
people in the world and I've always been
really passionate specifically about
environmental sustainability and
conservation probably some of that comes
just growing up in the beautiful Pacific
Northwest I got this idea in my head
that I you know after I retired from
ballet I was gonna go study to be a
green energy engineer I retired actually
kind of early for a ballerina but a big
part of that was because I had this
dream to do something else as well and
so I went back to school I went to
Seattle you studied electrical
engineering and along the way found out
that I actually loved math and this was
astonishing for me because I absolutely
hated math growing up it was something I
never felt good at and I was in really
high level math classes in school you
know I took calculus in high school even
before I graduated early but I thought I
was really bad at it and I wasn't I'm
actually quite good at math but it took
until college and until I had teachers
who really encouraged me for me to even
think that that was an opportunity for
me I thought I was really gonna struggle
with the math classes and instead with
the right teachers and with the right
encouragement
I totally thrived so I added a math
degree along the way found out that
actually I was really passionate about
research and so I ended up now I'm in a
ph.d program at Cal Tech doing computer
vision research and specifically focused
on environmental sustainability and
conservation so where are you in that
process right now so I just finished my
second year I'll be starting my third
year in the fall alright so talk about
your path here as an intern at Microsoft
Research this summer so as I said I've
been really passionate about
environmental sustainability from the
time I was a child and when I actually
decided to go to Cal Tech I work with
Pietro Perona who is an absolutely
amazing advisor one of the reasons I
decided to work for his lab is that he
has shown this real commitment to
projects that are helping the world or
helping people and that was something
that was really important to me after I
finished my first year I was looking for
projects that would really further this
goal and I had previously done research
with camera traps which are this really
interesting way that technology has been
assisting people who study wildlife
conservation so instead of having to do
fieldwork or a catch-and-release
type study which is quite invasive
to monitor animal populations behavior
the density like what the effects of
climate change and urbanization are
they're able to just put cameras out in
the field their motion or heat sensor
cameras really the bottleneck there is
just sorting the images so these people
go through they put out hundreds of
cameras they do a large-scale study and
then they spend hundreds and hundreds of
hours just sorting the photos by what
they see I was at Caltech trying to
figure out what project I wanted to
start with and this group from the
National Park Service in the US
Geological Survey reached out to Pietro
and they said you know were really
interested in trying to find a way to
use computer vision to automatically go
through this process of detecting
animals classifying their species and
long-term maybe even doing individual
identification and I was like actually I
have a lot of experience with camera
trap photos already and that sounds
great so I started building models for
them and curating their data set and
then I had went to Grace Hopper last
year and at Grace Hopper I just so
happened to stop by the Microsoft booth
and I was talking to Aussie Roycroft and
you know I was like I don't really need
an internship I am not really sure that
it works with my PhD but I was curious
if you know what's going on at Microsoft
Research at the intersection of AI and
environmental sustainability and she was
like oh you should reach out to Lucas
tropi who at the time was the head of
this nature plus computing group that
was exactly what I was looking for like
somewhere where you could do AI for
environmental sustainability yeah I
reached out to him and he was like
actually where you know it's not been
announced yet but we were gonna start
this huge new program at Microsoft
called AI for Earth it was a really
serendipitous for me but it's also so
inspiring to see that Microsoft has made
this commitment so this is a
company-wide initiative to basically sit
at the intersection of sustainability
and AI hearing about that really
encouraged me to say okay ya know I'm
happy to come on for you
I'll help build your tools you know I
and and actually it's kind of perfect
because in academia I can build lots of
models but I'm not a team of software
engineers so if I build a tool it's kind
of difficult to actually get it
to where it's widespread and easily
accessible for the people that tool was
meant for an AI for Earth is this
awesome
bridge between that it gives people like
me the opportunity to build models build
tools that can use cutting-edge computer
vision algorithms to work with this
complicated data and then you actually
are able to use this team of software
engineers who are building api's and
building tools and dealing with the user
interface and you know hopefully by the
end of the summer we'll have actual
tools that scientists can use to
actually start sorting their data tell
us about the project then specifically
that you're working on as an intern here
what I'm specifically focusing on is I'm
taking these camera trap images and I'm
training detectors which are able to
look at an image and not only tell if
there is an animal in the image but
actually localize the animal you are
able to train models that work
astonishingly well on camera traps as
long as you are using them at exactly
the camera locations you've trained them
on but if we want these tools to be
something that's actually really
beneficial to the entire ecology
community biology community where
they're using these camera traps to do
their research we need to make sure that
if you are starting up in a new region
or even in a region we've dealt with
before but it's a completely new set of
cameras that these models will be able
to work for you as quickly as possible
yeah and so what I'm doing is I am
working on trying to train detectors
that are able to generalize well to
these new areas in these new regions I
don't know if you've heard of Zooniverse
but Zooniverse is this big citizen
science platform for scientists to get
crowd-sourced data annotations and 40%
of their projects or camera-trap
projects and the largest one is this
project called snapshot Serengeti where
these cameras have been out continuously
for ten years in Africa and I was
talking to this woman who has been
working with many different karma trap
groups all over the world and I asked
her what's your estimate like back of
the napkin let's do a calculation how
many active camera traps do you think
there are in the world right now running
and she was like thought about it
for a second and said at least 500,000
maybe a million wow that's amazing that
is you think about how cheap cameras are
some of these cameras are like a hundred
dollars yeah think about how well you
could monitor the effect of a new
science policy on your wild animal
population if you had the real-time
ability to put out a camera and just
track everything you saw and just stream
that data and you could actually build
sort of a global scale population
density map for all these different
animal species I don't think it's gonna
happen soon but I think it's definitely
going to happen and I'm hoping my work
can contribute to that tell us about
your advisor and the group you're in the
people that you're working with what
have you learned what's been your
experience so my direct boss is Dan
Morris he is gung-ho passionate about
saving animals and he has been a really
valuable resource for me just in terms
of learning what it takes to build a
tool that people can use he has a lot of
intuition about sort of how to navigate
the politics of a large company and how
to increase visibility and how to
basically make sure that people care
about what you're doing so that it
actually gets done yeah and that's
something that I hadn't really had to
think about as much before right I mean
I have an NSF fellowship so I basically
have the ability to work on what I care
about but I don't have to convince
anyone else to care about it yet but now
I'm realizing actually how important
that is I think the ability to share
your passions with others and to really
make it super clear like why you're
passionate about stuff and get other
people excited about it too it's
probably like the best way to make
things happen yeah that's a skill that
you will want in the future what's next
for you Sarah
well I'm going to work my butt off for
the rest of this internship hopefully
take advantage as much as possible of
the resources I have here I'm going back
to Cal Tech right when I finish being in
a PhD is it's a long haul but it's
exciting and it's kind of the first time
in my life that I haven't
to be thinking immediately about like
what does the future hold and I'm pretty
sure that if I just keep working in
areas I really care about that I'll be
able to find a way to continue to do
that after I finish my PhD and what
would you see yourself doing in the
future I don't know if Microsoft keeps
funding AI for Earth maybe I'll work
here I would love to continue to find
ways to bring a AI algorithms and bring
the skills that I'm gaining at Caltech
to play in areas where you can make a
huge impact but they traditionally don't
have access and hopefully you won't need
to look for places that have free food
yeah don't let me say I think being
really poor at least once in your life
is very good for you because you're not
afraid of it anymore
I hear ya what's harder ballet or
high-tech research ballet in some ways
you know doing research somewhere like
Caltech can be insanely difficult but I
don't wake up in pain every day and I
gotta say it feels pretty good to be
able to like get out of bed and not feel
like an 80 year old do you still dance
I do Caltech has a ballet club so I Club
yes the context ballet club I take
classes on Sundays on a wood floor in
the gym it's but it's nice to just keep
my toes in literally literally they're a
very it's been so delightful talking to
you thank you for coming in today thank
you so much this is really fun
[Music]
if you're interested in applying for an
internship at Microsoft Research visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]